newly revealed documents appear to link
president Trump's personal lawyer
Michael Cohen to payments from a Russian
oligarch with Kremlin ties the lawyer
for adult film star stormy Daniels
claims the Russian billionaire paid
Cohen roughly half a million dollars
through a shell company
the record shows several payments to
essential consultants LLC that attorney
Michael avenatti calls suspicious
essential consultants is the same firm
Cohn use to pay Daniels to keep quiet
about an alleged affair with mr. Trump
in 2006 Jeff Fugazi is in Washington
with the revelations Jeff good morning
good morning CBS News hasn't been able
to independently verify a vanadis claims
as he questions why the payments were
made but avenatti says Cohen misled
banks and federal officials in receiving
them Cohen is already under
investigation following raids at his
home hotel room and office in New York
early last month I mean this this is a
big deal I mean he had to have been
receiving this money for something in a
seven-page document attorney michael
avenatti claims that from October 2016
to January of this year Michael Cohen's
firm essential consultants LLC engaged
in suspicious financial transactions
totaling nearly four and a half million
dollars those transactions he says
included roughly five hundred thousand
dollars from Russian oligarch Viktor
Vekselberg through the US company
columbus nova cohen created essential
consultants in October of 2016 and used
it to wire a hundred and thirty thousand
dollars in hush money to stormy Daniels
to keep quiet about her alleged affair
with Donald Trump avenatti claims the
funds from the Russian oligarch quote
may have replenished the account
following the payment to miss Clifford
Vekselberg was one of several Russian
oligarchs sanctioned last month for his
close ties to Vladimir Putin in a
statement his spokesman said Vekselberg
has never had any contractual
relationship with mr. Cohen or essential
consultants Columbus Nova told us the
claim that Viktor Vekselberg was
involved in or provided any funding for
Columbus Nova's engagement of Michael
Cohen is patently untrue avenatti also
details payments from several major
corporations to Cohen's firm in late
2000
17 in early 2018 including nearly
$400,000 from pharmaceutical giant
Novartis and $200,000 from AT&T I'm CEO
Novartis president Trump held a dinner
meeting with the incoming Novartis CEO
in Davos in January I don't think it's a
good deal for the country and he has
been a vocal critic of eight teas
potential merger with Time Warner which
is currently being sued by the Justice
Department former federal prosecutor
Jennifer Rogers says Cohen could spend
decades in prison if the payments are
found to be illegal he could face bank
fraud there's a suggestion by avenatti
at least that he may have lied on his
forms to an fdic-insured Bank and also
if he really is taking money from
someone he knows to be Russian
then he's possibly acting as a foreign
agent Michael Cohen has not responded to
our repeated requests for comment AT&T
told us that essential consulting was
one of several firms and it used to
provide insights into understanding the
new administration Novartis said the
payments to Cohen's firm were focused on
US healthcare policy matters and
preceded the current CEO the Vardis also
revealed in its statement that it was
contacted in November of last year by
Special Counsel Robert Muller regarding
the payments to Cohen's firm and has
cooperated fully with the investigation
all of this suggests that the special
counsels investigation is months ahead
of the news cycle and moving quickly
Gail alright Jeff hey guys thanks you
know the oligarch and the adult actress
kept the headlines but I want to know
what these companies were buying you
know president Trump campaign on
draining the swamp when you pay for that
kind of access that is that's heavy
swampland behavior a lot of money
it seems very opposite to draining the
swamp doesn't it the plot thickens there